the behind the back three beat weave it
is one of the most requested moves that
I hear about and yes today we're finally
going to dive into it Drex here from
Drex Factor po sharing with you the love
of Po spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your brain and yes that's right I am
finally taking this request and showing
you how to get down those behind the
back weaves but before we dive in I just
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro light toys
spinballs and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non- business
friend of the channel Becca beckin thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission all right
so low key whenever I have done a live
stream Q&A in any point of the past 3
years this move comes up there's always
somebody who wants to learn how to do it
and don't get me wrong I get it the
behind the back weave definitely takes
everything that you know about the 3B
weave and puts it in a place where it is
immediately having a wow factor for
absolutely everybody whether they are a
flow person or not so in this tutorial
I'm going to take you through five
specific steps that you're going to need
to go through in order to get down a
behind the back 3B weave here
goes step one learn your behind theb
back
planes all right solo key the behind the
back weave is really challenging because
it is one of those things that happens
in what I refer to as a limited Mobility
space basically you are working in a
place where rather than having free
reign of what your hands can do you have
to stick them in a spot where they have
limited mobility and still control the
planes of the poy which is tough to do
so we're going to start this off by
learning how to control those planes
with each hand now how we're going to do
this is we're going to take a version of
a drill that I'm a big fan of namely
keeping the plane in one position as
your body goes around it and we're just
going to apply that in such a way that
we're changing the orientation of our
body relative to the POI and getting it
behind our back here's what that looks
like I actually want you to start with
the POI spinning forwards at your side
and what you're going to do is you're
going to start to turn away from from it
you want to wind up with the Poise
spinning behind your back if you look
back at it it's going to look like it is
spinning
counterclockwise you're going to have a
moment where your hand is going to
change its orientation from Palm up to
Palm down and then you're going to try
and continue on your way all the way
around to having your hand tucked behind
your back and the pois spinning over on
your left hand side let me show you that
from a couple other perspectives number
one as we're looking straight on here
I'm going to start to turn away from the
POI again it was spinning forwards
relative to me when I was looking at the
camera and as I turn away from it I'm
going to flip my hand upside down so
that my palm is now pointed towards the
ceiling and I'm going to keep on walking
until I wind up with my hand tuck behind
my back and the POI now spinning what
looks like reverse on my left hand
side here's that from the front so again
I'm facing over to stage left and I have
the POI spinning forwards on my side I
start walking around in place and right
about the time when my hand is coming
close to the small of my back I'm going
to switch from Palm up to Palm down and
keep on turning my body until I get the
hand all the way tucked behind my back
over on my left hand side and it looking
like the PO is spinning reverse relative
to me and of course then I want to make
my way back out really really really
important you want to work your way
through individually each and every one
of these positions if there's a place
where you find that the plane is getting
stuck go back to the last position where
it felt stable do 10 beats and then move
a little bit forward keep that stable
for 10 beats a little bit forward keep
that stable for 10 beats so on and so
forth until you can get all the way over
to getting your hand behind your back
and getting back out with ease and of
course once get that down with your
right hand you got to do the same
exercise with your left hand cuz guess
what we're going to need both hands as
we go on through this
process step two behind the back Tic
Tacs all right so you got down our
exercise of learning how to keep the
pois spinning with your hand locked
behind your back congratulations the
next step is to do the same thing that
we do when we're learning how to do a 3B
weave in front of us namely we're going
to work with learning how to do a Tic
Tac that is bending the plane of the PO
back and forth from side to side of our
body only this time we need to do it in
a spot where we cannot see that motion
goodness all right so for this one you
want to start with the PO spinning
reverse on your side and try and wrap
your hand around behind you in that
position that we were getting to in the
last uh exercise as you go back and
forth between these two positions you
want to try and make sure that you're
getting a nice little Cross Point
happening back away from you where you
can't see it I know it's a challenge one
of those things that is almost certainly
going to happen as you're learning how
to do this is that you're going to find
yourself hitting the backs of your legs
as you go back and forth the reason for
this being that number one you're still
unus to keeping your plane straight
behind your back and also two that
you're working from such a place where
your hand is kind of pointing your thumb
down at the ground this means means that
your planes are going to tilt off on a
diagonal rather than staying vertical
how do we fix this I'm so glad that you
asked one of those things that I find
really helpful for this is actually to
imagine that my palm is going to stay
pointed up towards the ceiling as it
sits behind me that way I always know
that I'm putting in the effort to keep
my planes as vertical as possible as
they go back and forth across my body
like so you want to try and learn this
of course with both hands so see if you
can get to the point where you can do 10
repetitions of a behind the back Tic Tac
with both your right hand as well as
with your left hand like
so step three behind the back two beat
weaves okay so once again we're going to
take what we do when we're learning how
to do three beat weaves in front of us
and use that as a template for what we
do when we're learning up behind the
back weaves so once we get down our tick
tacks like so we then want to work on
doing two beat weaves that is Shifting
one hand around the other as they go
back and forth in Split Time same
direction trick is we need to do this
with our hands behind our back okay so
this is going to be a little bit
different a challenge than the one that
we were just dealing with we want to try
and get both of our hands in play at the
same time and just like we do with two
be weaves in front of our bodies we have
to think that the hand that starts this
motion is the one that goes underneath
I'm going to start off by having my left
hand go underneath like so so it's
reaching to try and get in that space
between my right hand and my back as I
go back and forth here let me show you
that from straight behind me I think
left hand starts the right hand goes
over left hand starts right hand goes
over by the same token I also want to
work on trying to get my right hand to
tuck underneath my left like so and try
and make sure that I'm keeping enough
space between my left hand and my back
that my right hand can tuck underneath
and in between so the goal here is to
try and get 10 reps both going my left
hand on bottom and 10 reps going my
right hand on bottom as I go back and
forth again let me show you that from
the back so we want 10 reps with the
left hand on bottom
and we want 10 reps with the right hand
on
bottom step four over under
back all right so we're starting to
close in on our final exercises we're
getting down this behind the back 3 beat
weave now we need to talk about the
actual pattern of the 3 beat weave the
two beat just involves keeping the same
hand on top the entire way around
whether that happens to be the left hand
or it happens to be the right hand to do
a full 3 beat weave we have to alternate
which hand is on top and that means
learning a pattern that basically breaks
down to over under back over under back
with each hand and doing this behind our
backs is no exception all right so for
this exercise I'm actually going to wrap
up the PO in my left hand and practice
just doing this with my right hand to
start with so believe it or not this
actually starts off in the same place as
the exercise we did in the TW beat weave
where I'm trying to get my left hand to
tuck underneath my right hand that is my
right hand going over and I want to see
then if I can tuck my right hand
underneath my left hand before bringing
it back to the right hand side so again
that is my right hand goes over under
and back over under and back let me show
you that all the way from the back I
think my right hand goes over under back
over under back it's really important
that I'm looking to try and Tuck that
that right hand in between my left hand
and my body when it's over on the left
hand side here that is what ultimately
makes the whole pattern possible of
course as with all things we want to
learn this with the left hand as well so
we would start off with it reaching over
under and then back over under and then
back once again we're trying to get our
left hand from being in front of our
right hand and then tucking it between
the right hand and our back for that
second beat let me show you that from
the back we have over under back over
under back over under back but really
what this feels like is under over back
under over back because we're kind of
used to thinking of the bottom of our
wrists as being under rather than over I
know it's confusing but it will make
more sense with
practice step five Giant
wait what now what do Giants have to do
with doing the behind the back 3 beat
weave well truth be told I actually did
not get down a behind the back 3B weave
until I learned how to start moving my
body along with it see there's this
thing that happens when we try to do the
behind the back 3B weave without moving
our body and that is that our arms have
to work really really hard to do it
whereas if we get our body engaged in
helping out this actually makes it
considerably easier to get down the
behind the back 3 beat weave but I
didn't understand how to move my body
until I started learning how to do POI
Giants so POI Giants are literally just
performing reels but doing them with our
full arms so what I want to do is think
that I'm going to have my arms spinning
forwards in Split times same direction
over to Stage right and then as my left
hand goes down towards my ankles I'm
going to follow it all the way around to
stage left and then get my poise
spinning reverse in Split times Same
Direction with full extensions when my
right hand is going up and over I want
to follow it back over to the right hand
side and land back with my arms spinning
forwards over on stage right so I want
to think I follow my left hand to stage
left and my right hand to Stage right my
left hand is stage left my right hand is
stage right and eventually I want to
just be able to go straight back and
forth between these two sides now notice
that as this is happening I can no
longer move my feet to switch which side
of the stage I happen to be facing so
this puts me in a position where that
motion has to come from my body core I'm
having to Pivot from my hips back and
forth and when that gets to feel normal
guess what that's the final piece of the
puzzle for getting down those behind the
back 3 be
weaves putting it all
together all right cool so now we know
the pattern of the behind the back 3B
weave and we've learned how to move our
body with it so it's time to put all
those pieces together it's time to start
off with the pois spinning reverse on
our sides and reach around to try and
get the right hand over and then under
and then back the left hand too we want
to get it over and then under and then
back and we want to switch back and
forth between these right over left over
right over left over again from the back
we get right over left over right over
left over right over left over right
over left over just like that I say just
like that this takes some practice but
you'll notice that as I'm doing that I'm
turning my body back and forth and I'm
keeping in mind that over under back
motion those pieces will come together
to produce this move I promise cool so I
hope that was helpful if you learned
this move please post video of yourself
doing it to either Instagram or Tik Tok
and make sure to tag me I would love to
see your great work did you get anything
out of this video please make sure to
like comment share and subscribe to help
other people find it and to help my
channel
[Music]
grow
this video would not be possible without
the contributions of my awesome
supporters on patreon in particular I
want to give a shout out to my flow
patrons who are listed on screen now um
if you'd like to check out more
tutorials that I have done in a variety
of intermediate level poy tricks I'll go
ahead and include a link to a playlist
of those down in the description and
also too if you would like to sign up to
support the channel I will include a
link to my patreon down there as well
thanks again for watching make sure to
get out and flow today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon peace